allez on va on va commencer à à parler
de notre baromètre d'xa évidemment on va
continuer à parler de cette crise
agricole puisqu'on va parler de Gabriel
àal mais d'abord comme tous les mois on
va regarder la popularité de l'exécutif
on commence par Emmanuel Macron Emmanuel
Macron Erwan qui est en très légère
baisse il perd un mois un point pardon
depuis le le mois dernier à la question
diriez-vous qu'Emmanuel Macron est un
mon Président de la République oui et ça
c'est la première information c'est
peut-être la plus importante aussi c'est
que si on rend bobine tout ce mois de
janvier 2024 on était quand même sur un
mois de rendez-vous avec les français
pour Emmanuel Macron de recherche d'un
second souffle pour le quinquena ce
qu'on observe c'est une stagnation même
une légère régression l'hypothèse qu'on
peut faire c'est que il y a peut-être eu
un effet rebond lié à la nomination à
Matignon du champion de l'opinion
Gabriel à tal mais que dans le même
temps il y a peut-être eu un recul dû à
un gouvernement dont le casting a
fortement déplu il y a aussi la question
du regroupement des ministères de
l'Éducation nationale et des Jeux
Olympiques les sorties d'Amélie ouactera
qui ont pas été apprécié non plus et il
y a une prise de parole très longue dans
un contexte de parole démonétisée du
chef de l'État qui n'a pas plus non plus
ça explique que ce qu'Emmanuel Macron a
probablement gagné en nomant Gabriel
Atal à Matignon il a peut-être aussi
perdu avec une prise de parole qui n'a
pas convaincu les les Français et un
gouvernement dont la composition n'a pas
convaincu les Français non plus on va
parler de gabrielalcla sur Emmanuel
Macron est-ce que ça veut dire qu'il a
raté son rendez-vous avec les Français
c'est vrai qu'on ils avaient fait un
teasing de de ce rendez-vous on
comprenait pas vraiment en quoi ça
allait consister on savait que ça allait
être feuilletonné pour le moment on a eu
l'épisode 1 qui était cette grande
conférence de presse à l'Élysée en prime
time c'est vrai que c'était un objet
médiatique un peu un peu déconcertant
quand même c'est 2 he de avec il y a eu
des polémiques sur les questions des
journalistes donc il a balayé énormément
de sujets il a envoyé des messages
politiques sur les européennes son
soutien à Rachid Anati Amélie UD ctera
qui était déjà dans dans la tourmente
mais c'est vrai que on semblerait en
tout cas les les audiences n'étaient pas
n'étaient pas forcément incroyaable et
ça n'a pas en tout cas donné C ce nouvel
élan ce nouveau cap qui était attendu
après c'est vrai ce qui était étonnant
c'est queon attendait tous ce discours
de politique générale on se disait bon
benah voilà il y a un nouveau Premier
ministre et finalement la prise de
parole du président avant celle de ce
premier ministre très populaire a pu
donner l'impression même si s'en est
défendu hein pendant la conférence de
presse il a dit qu'il allait pas faire
un discours de politique générale que
c'était son premier ministre mais ça a
un peu une fois de plus brouillé le le
message je pense sur qui gouverne
vraiment quel est quel est le cap et
peut-être que du coup voilà ça ça a raté
ça a raté sa cible après il devait y
avoir d'autres rendez-vous qui pour le
moment voilà ne sont pas forcément à
l'agenda étant donné de la la crise qui
qui qui est traversée et puis là bah il
a eu des rendez-vous à l'internationale
il revient d'Inde là il part en Suède
son entourage a expliqué qu'il pouvait
pas décaler son entourage aussi assuré
qu'il allait rencontrer Ursula van
darleyon jeudi en marge du Conseil
européen extraordinaire et qu'il allait
plaider la cause des agriculteurs
français mais c'est vrai qu'on est dans
une séquence un peu où le rebond n'est
pas vraiment là ouais on va parler de
Gabriel hatalin très populaire vous le
disiez on va voir les résultats
puisqu'il est au cœur de notre baromètre
mensuel Mathias on commence d'abord par
la popularité Gabriel àal 48 % des
sondés estiment que le nouveau locataire
de Matignon est un bon premier ministre
Orian c'est pratiquement un Français sur
deux qui a donc une bonne opinion
Gabriel Attal alors sans vouloir
comparer ce qui n'est pas comparable
ellisabeth borne avait elle terminé son
passage à Matignon à 29 % d'opinion
favorable c'est un démarrage en trompe
diront certains puisque si on pousse la
comparaison un peu plus loin lors de sa
nomination ellisabeth borne comptait 41
% de bonnes opinions Jean Castex lui
était à 40 %. est-ce que sa nomination
est bien perçu pour autant plutôt oui il
a encore près d'un sondé sur de 49 %
pour être précis se dis satisfait par
son arrivée au manettes si on entre dans
le détail 9 % sont satisfaits de sa
nomination 40 % plutôt satisfait à
l'inverse 28 % se disent plutôt
insatisfait et enfin 22 % très
insatisfait une popularité forte pour
Gabriel à la tale mais qui est déjà en
léger recul par rapport au lendemain de
sa nomination sa popularité elle était
alors de 53 %. on va continuer dans
quelques instants avec vous Mathias mais
d'abord sur ces premiers chiffres heran
on le voit Gabriel Attal est beaucoup
plus populaire qu'Emmanuel Macron est-ce
que c'est rare euh oui alors c'est c'est
rare faut aussi préciser sur ce 48 % de
popularité aujourd'hui pour Gabriel
Attal qu'on est à un niveau très haut
aujourd'hui on parle souvent avec vous
de la trip polarisation de la vie
politique française entre la gauche le
centre et la droite extrême droite
aujourd'hui réunir 48 % de de soutien
c'est assez inédit après ça a déjà été
vu récemment mais c'est très rare ça a
été vu pour François Fillon qui était
plus populaire que Nicolas Sarkozi quand
il a décroché au début de l'année 2008
mais la différence de François Fillon
c'est qu'il s'est jamais imposé que
comme un collaborateur en terme d'ADN
politique rien n avait émergé c'est tout
l'enjeu pour Emmanuel Macron on en
parlait de cette baisse de popularité ou
cette popularité basse d'Emmanuel Macron
s'il veut bénéficier de la popularité de
Gabriel Atal Gabriel Atal va devoir
pouvoir exprimer son ADN politique qui
qui plaît aux Français et et c'est tout
l'enjeu c'est qu'il réussisse à exprimer
la pleine mesure de ce qui satisfait
l'opinion clair il est aujourd'hui un
atout pour Emmanuel Macon Gabriel
Atal je pense après juste un point de
vue méthodologique je crois que c'était
avant le mouvement VO la grose voilà
donc ça c'est quand même important ce
soutien ma ce sera intéressant de voir
comment voilà cette séquence la réponse
qu'il a faite et cette c'est un
communiquant c'est qu'on l'a vu là sur
sa botte de foin vendredi à ne pas
trembler enfin c'est je trouve que quand
même il avait voilà une une naisance
oratoire qui lui était reconnue depuis
longtemps c'est vraiment une machine
communicante qu'il est très voilà s la
sincérité il applique sa méthode on
analyse on fait le constat on agit vite
enfin ce qu'il a essayé de faire
rapidement quand il était à l'éducation
nationale et ça avait plutôt fonctionné
donc il a quand même ce cet atout cet
atout indéniable après c'est vrai que là
il rentre comme on l' souvent dit dans
le dur vraiment d'un conflit majeur avec
comme vous disiez une catégorie de la
population qui ne pèse pas beaucoup
électoralement mais qui symboliquement
est vraiment très très forte et puis la
crainte même si voilà le terme peut être
un peu calvodé mais de convergence des
luttes on voit que cette France des
tracass on voit les les les artisans du
BTP enfin du du bâtiment pardon qui
commencent à dire bah nous le GNR aussi
la niche fiscale nous elle va s'éteindre
qu'en est-il et qui commence à à à
manifester on a entendu des buralistes
dans l'Est on on a vu les taxis en toute
cette France comme vous disiez qui
souffre soit de la taxation des
carburants soit d'un manque de
considération de normes qui pourrait re
très très attentive à la façon don dont
cette crise va être gérée et et il est
pas à l'abri voilà d'être vraiment très
rapidement mis dans une situation
délicate donc oui je pense que c'est ça
peut être un atout parce qu'on l'avait
vu depuis des mois en fait depuis sa
nomination notamment au ministère de
l'Éducation nationale il caracollé en
tête en fait des personnalités qui
arrivaient à déminer des conflits mais
est-ce que là ce ce sera suffisant vu sa
sa jeunesse ça reste à prouver oua eran
c'est vrai que quand il a été nommé à
Matignon on a beaucoup parlé d'un effet
waou Gabriel hatal là quand on on voit
le sondage est-ce qu'on peut dire que
l'effet waou il dure un peu dans le
temps non mais parce que il est dans un
contexte quand même très très difficile
c'estàd que il y a cette crise des
agriculteurs qui est une vraie phase de
test de son épaisseur politique alors
que certains mettent en avant sa
jeunesse il y a eu les propos d'Amélie
oua casterra mais qui ont été en plus
feuilletonné avec de de nombreuses
affaires il y a eu la nomination et ça
ça se ressent juste les propos d'Amélie
oua casterra vous ressentez dans
l'opinion des conséquences sur la la
manière dont est vu ce gouvernemental
oui oui tout à fait on a vu que le le la
nomination d'Amélie oua casterra aux
deux ministères rassemblés était jugé
être une mauvaise chose par les Français
et que ses propos n'ont pas été ceux
d'une ministre pour les les Français
donc ça on l'a on l'a mesuré et on voit
bien que cet effet waou d'ailleurs il a
baissé entre la nomination de Gabriel
Attal et l'annonce du gouvernement qui
est arrivé dans un deè deè temps en fin
de semaine après sa nomination donc il y
a quand même cette difficulté là mais il
est quand même au manettees aujourd'hui
avec Emmanuel Macron qui n'est pas sur
le le territoire national pour être au
premier plan de de cette crise des
agriculteurs donc il y a une vraie phase
de test de son de son épaisseur
politique et un enjeu alors qui arrive
tout de suite mais dont il peut sortir
gagnant et sur lequel il peut conforter
sa popularité ça veut dire que il joue
gros cette semaine un sur son discours
de politique générale deux sur la
gestion de cette colère des agriculteurs
ben c'est vrai que dans son discours
d'investiture si on se souvient bien il
avait placé l'ordre c'est un discours
très sécuritaire he quand même comme une
une priorité absolue alors évidemment ça
sortait d'une séquence politique où bon
on voyait derrière l'idée d'aller
attirer l'électorat de de centre- droit
voilà mais c'est vrai que c'était
vraiment central donc là on est dans un
moment où il y a des barrages où il y a
des des mutualités voilà sociales qui
qui qui qui agricoes qui qui flambent
enfin même si encore une fois c'est
c'est mesuré il y a quand même un risque
voilà de d'être à l'épreuve de ce de ce
de ce ce mouvement social qui pourrait
dégénérer donc là il joue quelque chose
c'est vrai que ce discours de politique
générale il va apporter des réponses sur
l'agriculture mais il doit vraiment être
voilà une une feuille de route sur des
sujets où ils sont très attendus parce
qu'il avait aussi dit que l'éducation
était sa priorité qu'il avait quitté son
ministère comme vous disiez avec en plus
une nomination assez contestée mais que
l'éducation restait sa priorité les les
enseignants là sont un peu dans une
situation complexe parce qu'en plus
apparemment Milie oud caster a reporté
sinédier certains certains certains
rendez-vous on est dans l'attente de la
suite du gouvernement aussi y a quand
même un vrai problème sur des ministères
vraiment majeurs comme le logement le
transport aujourd'hui il y a pas
d'interlocuteur donc là il va devoir
aussi donner d'autres signaux il y a le
plein emploi qui est aussi un autre cap
de de ce de ce gouvernement comment
enfin on va il a annoncé Emmanuel Macron
l'acte 2 de la simplification et puis de
mesures pour le marché de l'emploi qui
doivent arriver mais c'est aussi un test
pour les pour les syndicat donc voilà
tout tout ça fait que on a on a
effectivement un gros enjeu et puis une
greffe des enseignant jeudi hein qui va
être assez importante apparemment enfin
donc bon voilà c'est c'est vrai que là
aujourd'hui c'est ça va pas être écouté
que par les agriculteurs et justement
vous parliez de la manière dont doit se
comporter dont peut se comporter Gabriel
Atal vous l'avez mesuré ça aussi Erwan
on on va voir les résultats comment les
Français projettent Gabriel Atal dans
les mois à venir Mathias alors déjà un
sé sur deux estime que Gabriel Attal ne
sera pas qu'un simple collaborateur hein
comme le veut l'expression consacrée par
Nicolas Sarkozi on l' évoqué à l'instant
il considère les Français qu'il exercera
pleinement sa fonction un petit bémol
toutefois 54 % de ces mêmes sondés
pensent qu'il ne parviendra pas à
diriger avec autorité les ministres de
son gouvernement on pense évidemment là
au poids lourd du gouvernement avec en
figure de prou Bruno Le Maire Gérald
armanin et Rachid adati enfin dernière
projection et c'est la moins favorable à
la question Gabriel Atal ferait-il un
bon candidat pour représenter la
majorité présidentielle en à l'élection
2027 de 2027 bien seul 38 pour des
personnes interrogées répondent oui et
Mathias un point sur l'image qu'ont les
Français de Gabriel Atal globalement
c'est une image plutôt positive he qui
ressort de cette enquête pour 70 % DESC
des Gabriel Atal est dynamique 70 % 66 %
le trouve même sympathique il serait
selon 61 % ouvert au dialogue compétent
pour 55 % et enfin proche des
préoccupations des Français pour 47 %
des personnes interrogés voilà donc une
image plutôt positive he Air One mais
effectivement vous le disiez l'enjeu
pour Gabriel Atal est-ce que ça va être
de se démarquer d'Emmanuel Macron de
montrer qu'il n'est pas le collaborateur
du président de la République oui tout à
fait c'est ça une image très positive et
qui compense des faiblesses d'image
d'Élisabeth borne voire d'Emmanuel
Macron sur la proximité des Français sur
la sympathie sur l'ouverture au dialogue
maintenant il y a trois risques
aujourd'hui pour Gabriel Attal le
premier c'est celui du président
impopulaire dont l'impopularité pourrait
rejaillir sur lui il y a un risque aussi
c'est celui du gouvernement impopulaire
on l'a vu récemment avec Rachid Dati
Amélie ou ctera et il y a un troisième
risque pour Gabriel Atal c'est celui de
pouvoir exprimer son ADN politique
d'autorité républicaine de dynamisme
d'efficacité et de s'imposer sur des
thématiques c'est tout l'enjeu du
discours de politique générale pour
exprimer pleinement ce ce qu'il est et
imposer sa sa politique on avait vu si
on fait un parallèle la dernière
nomination du champion de l'opinion à
matigon cétait manuel Vals qui était
arrivé avec un niveau très haut de
bonnes opinions en 2004 14 après les
municipales très vite la popularité de
Manuel Vals a chuté jusqu'à ce qu'il
soit éliminé au premier tour de la
primaire de la de la gauche au début de
l'année 2017 donc c'est une trajectoire
assez rapide on peut lui souhaiter à
l'inverse une trajectoire à la Pompidou
qui a été premier ministre avant d'être
élu président de la République en 69
mais en tout cas aujourd'hui il va
falloir s'imposer pour Gabriel Atal
parce que Emmanuel Macron n'est pas un
levier pour sa popularité bien au
contraire ouais l'enjeu pour Gabriel àal
c'est d'imprimer une marque àal oui
alors bien sûr il y a le style mais la
l'équation parlementaire reste la même
c'est qu'il y a pas de majorité absolue
donc il va et c'est vrai que on est
l'alliance de circonstances avec LR sur
la la la réforme des retraites puis sur
la lo immigration était quand même
sacrément écorné là on le voit plus
comme un allié possible donc c'est vrai
que il va aussi avoir cet enjeu
d'arriver à à gouverner c'est-à-dire de
de d'être le leader de la majorité qui a
qui a vraiment souffert de de cette
épreuve de de la loi immigration on l'a
vu là avec le l'épisode de l'ascension
par le Conseil constitutionnel ça a
quand même recoué donc même si le
gouvernement a minimisé à voilà
présenter comme une victoire parce que
le texte essentiel était passé Gabriel
Atal arrive quand même dans ce contexte
euh donc ça va être ça va être compliqué
et après sur la méthode Atal c'est sûr
que cette perception et et sa jeunesse
on l'a vu quand il était porte-parole du
gouvernement par rapport à à la méthode
borne effectivement Emmanuel Macron a
fait le choix de la de la rupture donc
c'est vrai qu'on a un style totalement
différent mais il nen demeure pas moins
que politiquement la fin du quinquen va
être difficile et puis a cette horizon
des des européennes qui la dernière
grande élection avec Emmanuel Macron
voilà la présidentielle et et puis ce
face à face qui se dessine avec le le RN
et pour lui ça va être ça va être tout
l'enjeu ouais et justement le face à
face avec le reen on va peut-être le
voir on va regarder le le dernier
indicateur le baromètre de de popularité
le palmarès de l'adhésion là c'est
pareil c'est quelque chose que vous
mesurez tous les mois les résultats de
ce mois-ci Mathias et bien c'est que le
la première la personnalité politique
préférée des Français bien c'est Gabriel
atan il s'est propulsé à la première
place directement avec 44 % d'adhésion
ça devient le champion de de la
popularité et des opinions il devance
pour la première fois l'un de ses
prédécesseurs Édouard Philippe qui garde
tout de même 40 % de taux d'adhésion les
3e et 4e places de ce classement sont
tenus par le rassemblement national 37 %
pour Marine Le Pen et 33 % pour son
dauphin Jordane Bardella que l'on
présente parfois comme l'anti à natal le
jeune président du RN reste 11 points
derrière celui que certains présentent
comme son son rival pour les européennes
ouais arwan depuis qu'on est ensemble
tous les moins pour parler de ce
baromètre on parlait de l'indétrônable
Édouard Philippe qui occupé la première
place de de ce baromètre depuis des mois
et des mois et et ce mois-ci il a été
détrôné ouai tout à fait et puis c'est
c'est intéressant de voir que il est
détronné par une personnalité qui est en
fonction sur le plan politique alors que
lui est plus en retrait de la scène
nationale donc une personnalité en
fonction qui le dépasse ça montre qu'il
y a vraiment un effet Gabriel Atal dans
dans l'opinion qui est très puissant on
parlait tout à l'heure de l'indicateur
ferait un bon candidat pour la majorité
présidentielle en 2027 sur celui-là
Édouard Philippe reste encore un cran
devant Gabriel Atal mais Gabriel Atal
remonte alors qu'Ed Philippe a tendance
à stagner donc il y a aussi l'enjeu de
la succession d'Emmanuel Macron derrière
ce ce duo de de tête du palmarès de de
l'adhésion mais c'est intéressant à
suivre et c'est particulièrement
significatif que alors qu'il est sous le
feu sous les feux des projecteurs
Gabriel Atal se place en première
position ouais clair vous parliez il y a
quelques instants de ce duel entre la
majorité le RN on le voit sur ce
palmarès les deux premières
personnalités sont de la majorité les
deux suivantes Marine Le Pen Jordane
bardellaa du RN est-ce que ce palmarès
il incarne aujourd'hui ce duel dans
l'opinion bah les oppositions de gauche
qui sont qui sont assez peu audibles en
ce moment dénonce face- à face quiessaye
un peu d'installer Emmanuel Macron mais
c'est vrai que par le choix d'atal c'est
une autre méthode pour contrer le RN en
fait c'est se dire enfin tout son
discours d'ailleurs à Gabriel était
là-dessus les classes moyennes la France
qui souffre qui qui qui qui qui doit
mieux gagner sa vie par son travail il y
a une stratégie qui est voilà très
clairement ciblée sur un électorat qui
pourrait être tenté par le RN et c'est
vrai que dans l'approche des élections
des élections européennes la petite
phrase d'Emmanuel Macron qui était très
politique pendant sa conférence de
presse où il voilà il expliquait que
c'était un peu l'opposition entre deux
Europes voilà et vraiment clairement il
dénonçait le populisme et l'extrême
droite qui pourrait faire une entrée
massive aux élections européennes on
voit bien que le le duel il est là il
est entre toile de fond de tout et en
fait le rassemblement national que ce
soit sur la crise agricole actuellement
que ce soit sur la censure d'une grande
partie de projet de loi immigration un
boulevard en fait pour faire valoir ces
arguments qui depuis longtemps le sont
c'est dénoncer voilà les les les les
traités européens qui viennent empêcher
de légiférer dans le sens de l'opinion
publique enfin il y a vraiment un enjeu
là dans l'opinion et je pense que
pendant toute la campagne ils vont
surfer sur cette sur cette vague et et
c'est vrai que ça ça les porte et un
dernier mot rapidement arwan est-ce que
ce duel exécutif enfin majorité
présidentielle RN il est installé dans
l'opinion et est-ce que c'est paradoxal
de voir que dans les intention de vote
le RN est largement en tête alors que là
on voit ce sont deux personnalités de la
majorité qui sont en tête dans les
palmarès d'adhésion oui alors ce que ça
indique c'est que l'adhésion ne signifie
pas intention de vote et on le on le
voyait tout à l'heure avec la popularité
d'Emmanuel Macron aujourd'hui le
président est très majoritairement
impopulaire on sait que c'est lui qui
incarne la majorité présidentielle dans
l'esprit des des Français il n'aborde
pas et c'est ce qu'indique les
intentions de vote les élections
européennes en position de force on sait
que c'est un scrutin qui bénéficie
généralement au rassemblement national
ça a été le cas lors des derniers
scrutins mais là le rassemblement
national a l'air de largement creuser
l'écart et même en projection en nombre
de sièges donc il il y a quand même
cette inquiétude et qui n'est pas comblé
qui peut être comblé peut-être par une
tête de liste qui qui plairait aux
Français mais qui pour l'instant reste
encore en suspend et on aura l'occasion
d' on se retrouve le mois prochain pour
un nouveau baromètre en attendant on
regarde ce qu' a la une de nos
quotidiens régionaux
[Musique]
et mathas c'est la colère des
agriculteurs qui fait la une de la
presse régionale sans surprise le sujet
occupe une large partie des unes de la
presse quotidienne régionale dans cette
semaine sous haute tension comme nous le
rappelle Var Matin des agriculteurs qui
sont prêts à tout nous explique le
journal La Provence avec cette vache
casquette vissée sur la tête à la unee
du quotidien en Champagne l'Union titre
sur une colère des agriculteurs qui
serait organisé pour duré en iser le
Dauphiné Libéré fait de la pédagogie et
et détail à travers une série de
portraits les raisons pour lesquelles
les agriculteurs ne s'en sortent plus la
voie du Nord annonce que tout ce petit
monde peut-être est suspendu aux
annonces du gouvernement tous pas
vraiment puisque certains passent à
l'action comme les tracteurs Laurin qui
sont en route pour Paris nous dit le
républicain Laurin il existe aussi
d'autres modes d'action oui plutôt que
d'assiéger la capitale des agriculteurs
s'en prennent aux hyp et aux
supermarchés de leur territoire ici
l'ardénis et la montagne donne des
exemples à Charleville Maisière et dans
le puit d'Ô objectif de l'opération
déénoncer les méthodes de la grande
distribution maillon indispensable de la
chaîne alimentaire l'autre temps fort de
la journée ce sera le discours ce sera
l'Assemblée nationale pardon ouais le
discours de politique générale tant
attendu de Gabriel Attal on l'a bien
assez évoqué le Premier ministre sur
lequel toute la tension est portée dans
ce contexte de tension assiégé titre
même la Marseillaise il doit prendre la
parole devant les députés ce mardi avant
de renouveler l'exercice demain mercredi
au Sénat Gabri ri Attal est attendu sur
des sujets tels que l'éducation la
sécurité le pouvoir d'achat la santé le
travail et vous vous en doutez la crise
agricole allez on termine sur un sujet
plus léger oui quelques bonnes nouvelles
he dans ce monde de brut quand même
petit pied de nez à l'actualité de la
part de Paris-Normandie et de nordéclair
qui décide hasard ou pas de nous parler
tourisme tous les deux ce mardi le
journal normand roule des mécaniques sur
la fréquentation de rouan en 2023 année
record avec 4,4 millions de touristes
l'édition lilloise de nordéclair préfère
se concentrer sur les musées de la M
là aussi c'est une année record avec
plus de 1,2 million de touristes merci
Mathias on regarde une autre une des
journaux du groupeB c'est l'est
républiain la grande sociale gagne du
terrain et c'est évidemment le thème de
bcou de journaux du groupebra ce matin
merci Claire Planchard merci d'avoir été
avec nous merci Erwan pour ce baromètre
et vous avez merci à tous de nous avoir
suivi prochain rendez-vous c'est à 22h
Thomas H sens public et puis vous
suivrez bien sûr sur notre antenne le
discours de gabrielal devant l'Assemblée
nationale tout au long de l'après-midi
merci à tous de nous avoir suivi à
demain
[Musique]